[Music]
let's talk about the economics of cloud
how much does it cost to be on cloud
what happens if I move some of my
resources from my data center to cloud
how long is it going to take and if I
have to pay monthly what will my monthly
bill be how do I know that
AWS gives you a lot of tools to manage
your cost before you hop onto AWS cloud
or after you have made the move to cloud
then once you have been on cloud for a
while and we'll take a look at all of
these things so at the very beginning at
a very basic level it is the
pay-as-you-go model it is not a capex
model that is capital expenditure model
it is an OPEX model so you pay only for
what you use you do not have to pay a
fee or anything and you can get a volume
discount as well so if you are a large
organization and you have multiple teams
and multiple accounts for AWS you can
have a billing option where you will
have one person one account that is
going to pay the bill for all of the
accounts in the organization and the
benefit you get from doing this is a
volume discount
there are three tools that we are going
to look at now one is known as the AWS
cost calculator and what the AWS cost
calculator does for you is it tells you
how much you'll be charged for each
service for all the resources that you
are going to use it will calculate and
tell you your monthly bill so in this
scenario we are looking at a very simple
implementation where we have a dev
environment a QA environment and a broad
environment in dev and QA we have one
server each that we are choosing as G to
medium and in broad we have two servers
we know that broad is going to run for a
very long time so we are using the
billing option of a one-year partial
payment and then we get a lot of
discounts if we know that this workload
is going to be required for up to three
years then we can select this option and
we'll get up to a seventy-five percent
discount now this is only for servers
down below we have used EBS volumes
which are just hard drives and then I
also selected three volumes one each for
dev QA and production and then I also
added how much snapshot data I'm going
to have every month if you see on the
top of here that I get the monthly bill
now this is something only for ec2 I
could use the same thing for my database
as well so I will have some databases as
well and I can add all the databases I
need apart from this if I scroll down
here there are so many services on your
left that you can see that if you want
to use all these services and it will
just let me know what the monthly
charges for all of these things so this
is something you can do before you hop
onto AWS there are servers I have at my
disposal in my data center and then I'm
going to transfer my workload my
application all my data to the cloud how
much am I going to pay and this is a
tool that is used day in and day out by
pre-sales persons by solutions
architects by executives who want to
know beforehand how much they're going
to pay on the same line we have
something called PCO calculator that is
the total cost of ownership calculator
now here we can also add the manual
labor that we have the personnel that we
have the power that we have and it goes
into more granular details of the
resources that we have it just gives you
a total cost of ownership and this is
why these two things are very very
beautiful things if you want to know
beforehand what will happen if you move
some of your workload to cloud and you
get a very very very good idea of the
cost that you are going to spend in
cloud on a monthly basis coming back to
AWS console within the console there's a
tool called AWS trusted advisor that
essentially checks your implementations
so once you are on the cloud once you
have added all the sources on the cloud
from your databases your servers your
storage your cache everything then the
AWS trusted adviser checks all that you
have done and then it gives you
recommendations on four different things
among those four things are the cost
optimization which will tell you that if
you are using these workloads for
production you might want to convert
them into a reserve pricing option
so there are on-demand pricing options
there is a reserve pricing option and
then there's a spot pricing option
Reserve is the one that you use if you
know you are going to run this workload
for a period of one year two years or
three years then you can buy that
capacity in advance from AWS
and you don't have to necessarily pay
all the money upfront you can do a
partial payment for one year and you
still get up to 40% of the discount
which is really beautiful apart from
your cost AWS trusted advisor also gives
you recommendation on performance on
security and fault tolerance so if you
know some of your firewall routes are
not as stringent as they should be it is
going to scream at you please don't do
this if you can see here I have some of
my security groups that have instance
level firewalls or they have
unrestricted access so I have kept it
open for the entire world and I really
shouldn't be doing that
so these are the things that AWS
provides for cost optimization and for
cost management in cloud so even before
you are into the cloud or when you have
been in the cloud for a while you can
use these tools to optimize your costs
on a regular basis hey once become an
expert in cloud computing then subscribe
to simpler Channel and click here to
watch more such videos turner it up and
get certified in cloud computing click
here